it can be bright yellow orange or
reddish it's sticky slimy
and sometimes hard
i'm not talking about honey i mean ear
wax
the stuff that your body makes to
protect your ears
it has lubricating and antibacterial
properties
and now you're eating it
what would it taste like what would be
the effects of
eating earwax and
how long could you survive on that diet
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you ate nothing but ear wax
eating only earwax is a bad idea
i mean look at it gross
but it keeps out microbes and even
insects
weirdly it also keeps your ears nice and
clean
by helping your body get rid of unwanted
stuff
that's right whenever you chew or move
your jaw
you also move old earwax dirt
and debris out through the ear canal and
then
the bits and pieces flake off once they
reach the outside of your ear so
you shouldn't rush to remove all the wax
unless you wanted to try some well first
you'd have to figure out how to collect
it
if you're thinking about sticking cotton
swabs in your ear stop
if you push them in too far they could
harm your eardrum
it would be unbearably painful and could
even leave you
deaf instead use a special cerumenolytic
solution that's designed to dissolve
wax inside your ears and then flush the
stuff
out with a syringe and when you get
everything out
ah did you just find some tiny insects
in your earwax
gross but at least that's some extra
protein
right trust me you'd want all the
protein you could get when you learn
about the nutrients in your earwax diet
earwax is 60 dead skin about
20 fatty acids up to 9
cholesterol and alcohol
yeah before you ask your body produces
alcohol
it comes from the microbes in your
stomach which cause the fermentation of
carbohydrates
but it's unlikely that you would get
drunk from eating earwax
though you could get some healing-like
superpowers
all that dead skin is full of keratin a
protein that helps you to heal
in the past earwax has been used as lip
balm and
ointment for injuries but a healing
power wouldn't be enough to prevent the
increased risk of heart disease that
would be caused by the
intake of fatty acids oh yeah i forgot
to tell you that
earwax can show traces of certain toxins
in the body
like heavy metals so if you ate it
you'd be putting all that bad stuff back
in
and have you noticed something missing
from the nutritional value of earwax
yeah that's right carbs between 45 and
65 of your total caloric intake
should come from carbohydrates they're
in things like
bread potatoes and bananas but
there are no carbs in earwax so
this would be an extremely low carb diet
it could lead to heart problems cancer
kidney damage and sudden death
and you obviously wouldn't be able to
survive on
only your ear wax you'd need to pull
earwax together from other people
luckily some of us have more earwax than
others
some people have so much of it that it
can cause a blockage
and if you wanted to diversify the menu
you'd be happy to know that
different people have different wax wet
earwax is
more common in caucasians and africans
while
dry earwax is more frequent among native
americans
native hawaiians and asians your ideal
dinner would be
light brown or yellow since that's a
sign of healthy earwax
definitely stay away from dark brown
earwax
it's usually older with a lot of dirt
and bacteria but if i'm being honest i'd
stay away from earwax
all together leave that gross stuff
where it belongs
if you want to taste something made by
your own body
maybe you'd be better off eating boogers
[Music]
well that's a story for another
what if